bonjour bienvenue à la semaine verte la
friche le dit les animaux ne sont pas
que sur les panneaux pour améliorer la
sécurité routière est assuré aussi la
survie de certaines espèces
on a bâti depuis quelques années des
corridors qui permettent aux animaux de
circuler sous les routes mais un bref
survol de ces constructions nous
indiquent que leur bilan et parfois
mitigés pour elle le danger est
permanent
elles doivent surmonter des obstacles à
leurs risques et périls
comme ici sur la route 245 à bolton-est
en estrie
une voie empruntée chaque jour par 2000
véhicules qui file à vive allure
les petits reptiles en question circule
eux très lentement
il s'agit de la tortue serpentine la
tortue des bois et la tortue peinte
trois espèces dont le statut est
précaire
c'est des ennemis qui ont côtoyé les
dinosaures
donc il était là avant nous puis bas
risquent de disparaître à cause de nous
par nos routes par nous
nos actions de destruction d'habitats
ces tortues vivent aux abords de la
rivière missisquoi nord et de les
tempérer leur habitat est traversé par
la route 245
c'est problématique surtout au printemps
lorsque les femelles qui est des cours
d'eau pour allez fondre dans les espaces
sablonneux qui borde la route entre 2012
et 2017
23 tortues sont mortes sur ce tronçon de
route
[Musique]
ça nous a inquiétés parce que dans une
population
quand on dépasse 5 % de mortalité des
adultes ça peut vraiment être néfaste
pour une population on peut la voir
décliner très rapidement voilà la voir
disparaître l'eau du jus du milieu
corridor appalachien organismes de
conservation de la faune a eu l'idée
d'aménager des passages sous la route
pour tenter de préserver l'espèce
l'organisation a convaincu le ministère
des transports du québec mtq d'investir
dans les travaux correctifs lors du
remplacement d'un ponceau en 2017
deux passages ont été aménagés un
aquatique et un autre terrestre
[Musique]
une clause sur bord de la route sur 100
m pour empêcher les tortues de traverser
et les refoulés au bon endroit
c'est un lac brompton en estrie que le
premier projet d'écologie routière de la
province a été aménagé
en 1997 le biologiste daniel bergeron
circulent sur la route de saint fraigne
[Musique]
la voix séparent le lac brompton de
marais de cinq kilomètres carrés près du
parc national du mont orford en estrie
il aperçoit alors des centaines de
grenon et de rené trusses y faire et de
salamandre écrasé sur la chaussée
le fait d'avoir vu autant d'amphibiens
transhument je me suis dit je veux je
fasse quelque chose
un inventaire des mortalités révèle que
91% des amphibiens qui traversait trop
de pendant la période de reproduction se
font écraser tout ça parce que la route
50 de leurs corridor de migration
le biologiste identifié une solution
déjà en vigueur au massachusetts des
tunnels pour salamandre il décide de
faire la même chose ici et sensibilise
l'opinion publique en invitant des
écoliers à se transformer un brigadier
de la nature en 1999
une centaine d'enfants a aidé les
amphibiens a traversé la route 220
[Applaudissements]
l'initiative attire l'attention des
médias nationaux
la plupart tournent son projet de tunnel
à amphibiens en dérision
j'ai eu la chance d'avoir tout dans les
médiaux des caricatures des lignes
ouvertes âge et j'ai vraiment tout pour
ce projet leur mais daniel bergeron fini
par convaincre le ministère des
transports de construire trois ponsot en
béton polymère sous la route pour
permettre aux amphibiens de se rendre au
marais en toute sécurité
des barrières de déviation sont
également installés pour diriger les
amphibiens vers les passages faut dire
que c'était le premier au canada
c'était le deuxième en amérique gens
donc c'était vraiment très
innovateur un projet
[Musique]
avez vous gardé tout fonctionne bien
durant plusieurs années
[Musique]
mais par manque d'entretien les
installations sont devenus peu à peu
inutilisable
pour mieux le voir bon ben voilà
normalement l'entrée est libre pour les
enfants n'est plus passé
on voit là la clôture de déviations et
cie qui est carrément sublimé par la
végétation et les feuilles et puis en
fait la clôture était vraiment supporté
par le fils comme ceux ci à la fin de
l'été dernier le ministère des
transports a dû intervenir d'urgence sur
le site
les ponceaux faisait gondoler la
chaussée et rendait la circulation
automobile dangereuse
les tunnels ont été démolies et la route
a été et reste valide et il ne reste
plus aucune trace des passages à
amphibiens qui avait attiré l'attention
du pays tout entier
le mtq évalue s'il pourra ou non
reconstruire de nouveaux passages
[Applaudissements]
de 2006 à 2011 le ministère des
transports s'est attaqué aux plus gros
projet d'écologie routière de la
province celui entourant l'élargissement
de la 175
[Musique]
pour la première fois au québec on se
préoccupe de l'impact de la construction
d'une route sur la petite et moyenne
forme
[Musique]
on était un début dans le fonds de
développement de cette science l'eau
québec
et si c'était un laboratoire la 175 pour
les petits moyens mammifères la route
entre stoneham et le
saguenay-lac-saint-jean traverse la
réserve faunique des laurentides et
longe le parc national de la
jacques-cartier
à l'époque elle est l'une des plus
dangereuses pour les automobilistes
on l'a longtemps surnommée la route des
coroners
en l'élargissant quatre voies le
ministère la rend plus sécuritaire
mais il crée un obstacle encore plus
important pour la faune de la forêt
boréale
ils sont capturés mais demandant des
parcelles qui restent dans les passages
qui sont beaucoup plus petits l'impact
qu'on voit le plus facilement c'est la
mortalité routière
beaucoup d'animaux sont tués sur la
route
[Musique]
de 2012 à 2015 l'équipe de jochen jager
a recensé 900 carcasses d'animaux sur ce
tronçon de route
ce nombre serait bien en deçà de la
réalité puisque les relevés ont été
faits durant une courte période de
l'année pour tenter de régler problème
33 passages ont été construits la
plupart ont été utilisées avec succès
certains sont fréquentés par une dizaine
d'espèces lièvres renards ou castor
mouffette marmotte hermine porc-épic
visons même l'ours noir ya traverser
[Musique]
c'est certain qu'à un simple tuyau comme
celui là c'est pas couplées avec des
clôtures qui vont canaliser mouvement
bataille qui va être pas très efficace
dans ce cas ci on a mis 100 mètres de
clôture de chaque côté qui ont la forme
un peu d'entonnoir qui vont canaliser
les mouvements les animaux qui en prend
que les passages grâce à ces clôtures
ont effectivement la vis aux cependant
un nombre d'animaux plus élevé que prévu
chercher à contourner les clôtures pour
rejoindre la route explique écrasé en
bout de ligne la mortalité est la même
dans les trois sont clôturées que ceux
qui ne sont pas l'animal tarif de la
classe une condition je vais à gauche ou
à droite
dans certains cas il va se relancer au
lieu-dit ce passage sur la chose donc on
émet l'hypothèse que si nos clôtures
étaient plus longues on aurait pu avoir
une réduction plus significative des
collisions
l'instance est pas prévu de les allonger
bonnes questions budgétaires je me suis
essentiellement pour une question
budgétaire
le chercheur yoga n'y a guère s'en
désole ce serait important et
intéressant de le faire parce qu'on est
dedans un réserve faunique y est on un
proche du parc national alors si on ne
veut pas faire ça ou est ce qu'on
devrait commencer
à bolton-est on a récemment fait le
bilan des deux premières années
d'opération des passages à torture
les images captées par les caméras
électroniques montrent que le passage
aquatique et le plus populaire des deux
on a vu bien sûr des tortues qui ont
utilisé passages aquatiques tortue
peinte au dessus serpentine mais aussi
le tout une gamme d'espèces fauniques là
dans les canards des ligues renault et
castor rang musqué visons l'hôte de
rivière
et une seule tortue est morte écrasée
sur la route depuis 2018
les aménagements qui ont été réalisés au
niveau de l'étang peas les bains ont
permis de réduire la mortalité mais
subsiste tout de même une inquiétude
il y a moins de tortues en vie sur ce
tronçon de route les populations visées
étaient peut-être déjà décimé au moment
de la mise en place du projet on peut
penser que les les populations ont été
affectés le par le passé par la
mortalité puis que le nombre de torture
dit louise
l'organisme espère maintenant que des
tortues d'autres secteurs qui aideront
recoloniser l'endroit et donner un petit
coup de pouce aux chances de survie de
l'espèce
trois projets d'écologie routière
réalisée sur deux décennies dans des
régions et des conditions différentes
le québec on est encore aux
balbutiements
quand vient le temps des tenues et
l'impact des routes sur les habitats
fauniques